there is no end in sight to the slowdown
affecting global trade and experts say
you better buy your christmas presents
as early as possible why because you
want to avoid any shortages this morning
we're taking a look at what's behind
this gridlock raimi inocencio in china
shows the supports and factories that
are having trouble getting their
products to this country then carter
evans goes to one of those businesses
that is waiting for the goods to come to
the ports of los angeles and make their
way to the state of new
york good morning from a helicopter
above hong kong one of the world's
busiest cargo terminals is just right
there in mainland china it's called
gantin and it is so important to u.s
china trade because about a quarter of
all the goods buys from china gets
processed through this one
it's how american philip richardson gets
his high performance speakers to u.s
consumers that's been tough since the
summer power cuts have been rippling
across eastern china and still are if
we're shut down for more than 15 minutes
then it creates a headache
the electricity was on when cbs news
visited his factory in guangzhou china's
manufacturing metropolis workers
assembled speaker drivers installed them
in cabinets and boxed them up bound for
the u.s up to 2 000 in a day
richardson says the blackouts have been
wasted time and money and sometimes
there's
no notice
they'll uh they'll the power is shut
down and then 30 minutes later we'll get
a call from the
from the village
kerr gibbs is president of the american
chamber of commerce in shanghai the
power supply problem here is somewhat of
a perfect storm china has been trying
hard to cut carbon emissions
but cuts in coal production have led to
record prices
utility companies hadn't been allowed to
raise their fees to match until recently
since they couldn't make money they
stopped making electricity
and it's not just a shortage of
electrical power but manpower at the
ports because of covid
gibbs says workers must quarantine for
three weeks after working a two-week
window not an incentive to return
they can be exposed to the covet virus
coming in through the supply chain so
that's what china is worried about
between the quarantines the power
outages and the manpower problems it's
all led to higher costs even before
those speakers leave china we're feeling
the price pressures now
i'm carter evans here in middletown new
york the costs keep adding up for those
speakers from phil's factory in china i
used to pay maybe 12
you know per
pair to get here now i'm paying like 60.
john haber is ceo of alto music he sells
instruments and electronics nationwide
and says shipping costs for everything
have skyrocketed so it takes
longer and it costs like five times as
much that's what a bargain
that's unbelievable haber started
stocking up when the shipping log jam
first hit the ports of la and long beach
so you got a room full of guitars yeah
that i ordered 15 months ago that are
just starting to come in now
that's how that's how delayed it is it's
nuts these tiny electronics are critical
to his top-selling audio device this is
uh
more valuable than gold to us but due to
shortages overseas i'm sending them to
china so they can make my products and
send it back to you exactly that sounds
crazy it's
it's nuts many of these businesses are
having a really hard time keeping up
with the inflationary costs of shipping
bob biesterfeld heads a global logistics
company and fears the huge stacks of
containers at the ports will likely
remain without more truckers the
trucking industry today is still down
you know 60 or 80 000 drivers these are
simply just not things that i believe
are going to be solved over the course
of the next weeks or months and with the
holidays approaching john haber is
unsure how long his stockpile will last
so i could only suggest if you see
something that you know you want and
it's there buy it
buy it because you're not going to get
it
this week the port of los angeles
started fining companies for leaving
their containers here too long 100 per
day per container and up that's just
adding to the high cost of shipping and
americans addicted to cheap and fast
chinese goods are paying the price
all right carter evans best advice that
we heard if you see something buy
something yeah i guess that's the only
solution because it doesn't seem like
this is going to end in time for
christmas you know what you don't pay
attention guys to these stories until
it's something you want now all of a
sudden christmas is coming you're
thinking yeah i better get on it that's
why it's important when we do these
stories that people it's crazy it's a
wake-up call it's a wake-up call for
those of you watching you have the
holiday season you have birthdays you
might as well get what you see if it's
available that's right put it in the
storage space yeah and expect to pay
more too i know